قبل أربع ساعات طويلة من حدوث ذلك
قبل مقتل 156 شخصًا ، أصيب عدد لا يحصى من
الأشخاص بجروح قبل أربع ساعات طويلة من
اندلاع حشد من الزقاق الضيق
في سيول ، وتظهر السجلات أن الشرطة قد تم تحذيرها
من سحق خطير محتمل
للناس وحدث ذلك في حفل عيد الهالوين يوم
السبت
باعتباره حزينًا.  تجمع العائلات
متعلقاتها أو أحباءها من
صالة الألعاب الرياضية ، وقد أقر رئيس الوزراء وقائد الشرطة
بوجود أخطاء في
السقوف تحتوي باولا هانكوكس على تفاصيل
وأجزاء تحذيرية من تقريرها ، إنها
رسوم بيانية
[موسيقى]
كيف تتحول ليلة الاحتفال
إلى هذا
العدد الكبير جدًا  أشخاص في منطقة كرامبتون
يدعي شهود عيان قلة الشرطة ولا
يوجد مسؤولو مراقبة الحشود يقولون إن العديد من
رجال الشرطة تم نشرهم في أماكن أخرى
بالمدينة بسبب الاحتجاجات المتوقعة التي تعترف
بعدم وجود مبادئ توجيهية لمراقبة
هذا النوع من الحشود دون المنظم.
يعمل عبر الطريق يقول إن
الحشود كانت كبيرة بحلول الساعة 4 مساءً يوم السبت
بحلول الساعة 7 مساءً  كنت أتسرب إلى
الشارع
، أعتقد أنه كان من الممكن منع المسؤولين المحليين من
الشرطة ورجال الإطفاء
فحص المنطقة في اليوم السابق كان ينبغي أن
يعرفوا عدد الأشخاص الذين
سيخرجون هذا هو قلب ito1 وهنا
هو الزقاق الذي ينحدر
نحو الأسفل باتجاه الرئيسي  طريق حيث فقد الكثير من الناس
حياتهم ، يبلغ عرضه حوالي أربعة أمتار ويبلغ ارتفاعه
13 قدمًا ، ويوجد به جدار
فندق من جانب ومتاجر على
الجانب الآخر الآن قالت إحدى المستجيبين الأوائل عندما
وصلت إلى هنا ، كان كل ما يمكن أن تراه
يصل إلى 10 صفوف من  وجوه لم تستطع رؤية
أي أرجل مما يعني أن الضحايا كانوا مكدسين
فوق بعضهم البعض الآن هذا الزقاق الخلفي
هنا مليء أيضًا بالحانات
والمطاعم والنوادي الليلية التي رأيناها من
الصور فقط كيف كانت مكتظة في الواقع
رأينا رجلًا يحاول التوسع
خارج المبنى لمحاولة الهروب
من الازدحام ، وهنا يوجد
الطريق الرئيسي الأربعة الممرات التي
تم إغلاقها قبل أسبوعين فقط لمهرجان
أمام حركة المرور ولم يكن قريبًا من حركة المرور على
S  في اليوم مما يعني أن الناس قد تكثفوا
أكثر في هذه المنطقة على بعد 20 مترًا
من افتتاح هذا الزقاق هو
مخرج مترو أنفاق ظل مفتوحًا مما يسمح
للناس بمواصلة الوصول إلى المنطقة.يظهر
هذا الفيديو الذي تم التقاطه بعد الساعة 9 مساءً
كثافة الحشد في
الممر الضيق ، تظهر صورة بعد نصف ساعة
المزيد من الأشخاص لا يزالون يصلون
إلى المنطقة عن طريق مترو الانفاق ، لذا فإن ما
يبحث عنه المحققون هو دائمًا
مسألة البدء بالهندسة الأساسية التي
تبحث في تدفق الحشود ، هل كان
من المتوقع بشكل معقول
أن يتجاوز ذلك الأمان  حدود إذا كان
متوقعا بشكل معقول ، فإنه يمكن التنبؤ به
، ومن ثم يمكن منعه
، اعتذر قائد الشرطة يوم الثلاثاء
قائلا إن الاستجابة لمكالمات الطوارئ
لم تكن كافية ، حيث نشرت الشرطة
137 ضابطا فقط للتعامل مع
حشد قد يكون تجاوز مائة
ألف غالبيتهم المكلفة
بمنع الجريمة  ليس السيطرة على الحشود
روح بولا هانكوك في سي إن إن